by the power of castle hate skull i am
hella mark harley back with another
banger
back just yesterday i shot one that went
live on tuesday and i'll be full
disclosure with you guys it's wednesday
today we had a scheduling difficulty i'm
cranking out back to back episodes this
will be out
next week i'm recording this on a
wednesday and i just have some super
important very uh exciting news for all
of you as you may have known if you're a
follower of this podcast if you're
somebody who
tracks each episode and watches them
chronologically then you know a little
bit about my life and one of the things
that i was very excited about that i had
to stop talking about actually i'll tell
you about why i had to stop talking
about it in a second and stop divulging
more details because apparently some
people want to keep certain things under
wraps
i was in a hanson music video a couple
weeks ago i shot it i am the only person
in history to actually be in two
handsome music videos that's a
distinguished award that i possess and
honor that i am proud to bear look it up
in the guinness book of world records if
you don't have one that's not my issue
don't call me a liar that's
disrespectful now
as far as
when that's coming out
april 15th look for it on the hanson
youtube i'll be posting about it on
instagram i have had a chance to see the
finished product because the director
ever so gratefully
uh shared a link
to the final edit and i was like man oh
man i knew it was going to be good
thought it was even better when we're on
set and seeing how it all came together
it's an impressive feat of
music video storytelling and humor
and a lot of things coming together to
make something really unique and fun
that even ties into other music videos
that they're doing because i guess each
of the brothers is kind of like
doing their own little part of the album
and so uh you know one brother's
first lead single
has some
images uh that tie into this next music
video and so on and i always think stuff
like that is really cool like the layers
on top of things and the conceptual
uh albums and songs and
when you tie in little easter eggs from
other work that the artist has done
that's all cool to me so
and it's honestly a really good song i
can't play it i can't replicate it
but
i was like oh damn this is uh it's
something you might work out to actually
which is it'll you'll see how that's
appropriate but you know it's taking
some pictures on set and
if you saw it for two minutes posted my
story before somebody came up to me like
hey um where uh mark and they like
pulled me aside even though no one was
around me they're like mark um
they're trying to not post social media
i'm like what like they don't want
anybody to post to social media mike huh
they don't want anybody to bust the
social media oh oh yeah no i'll take it
i didn't know sorry yeah
i'll do that um
you know when somebody puts like when
they're like ah
are you afraid i'm gonna react and like
hit you or something like um
but uh i i appreciate the diplomacy but
yes i couldn't post any images i have
some funny behind the scenes stuff from
that am i going to talk about
the hanson music video for the first 10
minutes of this podcast that's what it's
looking like you know
i actually
i'm gonna jump to a mark harley meme of
the week just to set up the rest of what
i want to talk about
um you know we can't swear in the first
three minutes can we say the c word
c-o-v-i-d
mark harley doesn't get c-o-v id
c-o-v-i-d gets mark harley uh who gave
that to me i'm gonna have to give you
credit on the next one sorry i didn't
photoshop your name oh i hate doing that
but i also did post it to my story if
you see that i just think it's a great
little like
um chuck norris style meme i appreciate
that i think it's funny and it's timely
too that's the thing it's like you guys
you see an opportunity and these
photoshop masters and or even if you're
just playing around with it you have a
funny concept it's just cool to see it
like cranked out
you know that day or that week so
you know
there's also this meme i saw
oh here it is cool stuff on the internet
i want to set that up too
i was bringing it's this guy sitting in
a truck and the the meme is it's like
fake news i was brainwashed by the
liberal media then i saw a video of a
man ranting alone in a truck like that
broke the spell um
and i think that's funny
just because it's you know you will see
these guys ranting in a truck and it's
like
is that going to change somebody does do
political rants ever change anyone's
mind and that's a really interesting
psychological question and i think there
are ways in which to persuade somebody
but when i argue online or i debate or
the joy that i take in trying to be
right in a battle of ideas against
somebody else that doesn't really
revolve around persuading somebody if my
motives were different if i wanted to
persuade somebody to think differently i
would go about it in a completely
different way that circumvented the
responses your ego comes up with when
faced with information that you don't
like because most people dig in their
heels and reinforce their own beliefs
when confronted by somebody with
opposing views even if they're bringing
facts to the table that you may not have
considered so
speaking of politics since we are going
to make this a political podcast just
kidding but i do think there's certain
things that come up that
my kind of boundaries and rules for this
are like i'm not going to be like biden
sucks or i hate trump like that kind of
easy
partisan
preaching to the choir type of thing
like
you know obviously there's a lot to
complain about about the current
administration which i'm happy to
discuss in private but really you know i
like looking at other things and bigger
trends and kind of like
ironies
in the broader political landscape and
one of the most interesting topics to me
is
um
this sort of
authoritarianism
that people are okay with for various
reasons because especially we live in
america
and we pay a lot of lip service to
freedom and anti-authoritarianism and
people like you know gary kasparov who's
uh whose book winter is coming he's
almost sort of like
about
you know through the lens of
understanding putin and his ambitions
with russia you
get to this broader premise that the two
main opposing forces in the world are
authoritarianism and liberal democracy
and we do
as liberal democracies we kowtow a lot
to places like saudi arabia and we kind
of selectively criticize human rights
violations whatever like that's just
that's a non-controversial fact right um
we let china and saudi arabia get away
with a lot because we have business
interests there so like sometimes we'll
be you know
selectively um
critical of certain things but not if
our interests are big enough and and so
that's always an interesting like
through line and foreign policy if
somebody if america says you know we're
going in there to like save the kids
it's like aria though why didn't you go
over here um
you know there's usually an ulterior
motive
um but
you know
there's a great argument to be made that
if the entire world consisted of liberal
democracies there would be less war
violence oppression all the negative
things that go on in the world as far as
suppressing and undermining uh
the sanctity and freedom of the
individual you know
individual rights just don't exist in
these authoritarian regimes so
but at some point we stopped caring
right because
i always thought it was interesting one
of the main things if you're looking to
to figure out like what was the appeal
of trump if that still is lost on you
um
one thing that linked people who really
liked trump was a penchant for
authoritarianism he took a lot of kind
of strong man
um
notes you know out of the playbook of
these other strongmen in south america
or um
you know
in eastern europe uh
and that's a really interesting lens
through which to analyze things because
especially when
when the people believe a country or
society is in crisis we do often turn to
people who go like i have the answers
and i want to
use the power of government to effect a
quick solution rather than waiting for
the grinds of democracy to turn
especially when they're in gridlock like
we are today so how'd that come up with
kovid what am i doing here um i do have
a point because
this comes back to china if you've seen
that viral video of the guy ranting in
china okay so
china if you don't know this already is
in like a
they have a zero coveted policy so
everybody's locked down and like we say
lock down here like oh my god i couldn't
go to the grocery store and they
recommended that i stayed in my
apartment most of the time
china has an actual lockdown policy
where you're not allowed to leave your
door
you can't get groceries there's like a
supposed to be a system in place where
you have groceries delivered and you
know in theory
if you implemented something like this
you would think that they back it up
with assistance from the government that
would make sure you're able to eat
but apparently that's not the case and
obviously even in a place like china
where you risk your life by speaking out
politically against the uh chinese
communist party
there's still this and probably i don't
even know how to get it up to the
internet because it'd be censored you
know i don't know what that mechanism is
but we got a video of a guy ranting in
the street and it's all transcribed to
english but basically he's like
how do you expect me to like eat how do
i have mortgage to pay like this is
crazy like we're gonna die like i don't
have any food
i feel like there's a recipe like and it
was so impassioned so that's why i
wanted to set up that like trucker
ranting in his car it's like a lot of
that's hard for me to take seriously
most of the time because you know it's
often like anybody ranting in their car
it's like you know
i just you're you're worried about the
wrong things and i don't think they're
that immediate of a threat for you to be
like this country's so messed up that
like
everything's on the line for me but i
believed this guy
and it was just an interesting little
insight because i don't know how much
you think about different like i think
about north korea a lot i'm fascinated
with them and like just how oppressive
the society is and how you know so many
things that we take for granted
are just
you know not available to them speaking
your mind being one of them
or doing anything to protest the
government that that doesn't risk a real
uh chance of you
being killed you know very quickly so uh
this it's it's a pretty epic rant and
like
gives you an insight into what's
happening and how
um
this is an anti-scientific approach like
apparently there's no science that backs
us up and you should really in this case
i guess try to get vaccines to people
but even the vaccine isn't like the
chinese vaccine isn't that good but
they're not even like they're not
forcing people to take it over the first
people to stay inside and you can't even
care for your elderly you know relatives
and stuff like that so it's like
you know for some people there is this
death sentence element to what they're
doing in there and specifically sorry
not the whole country but shanghai and
maybe other cities too but like shanghai
is a giant city and uh they're literally
shutting it down to the point where you
can't even leave your apartment um or
where you know at some point
i assume that people there are going to
rise up against that but
it harkens back to the beginning of the
pandemic the two different political
sides
uh had these different responses but
were sort of like impressed by chinese
authoritarianism for different reasons
the left was like
look how they can respond in
uh you know in the name of like
the people are sick and need help look
how quickly the government can rush to
the aid by shutting things down
quarantining
um
you know implementing building hospitals
really quick i think was one thing
because like the big you know panic over
here was like oh my god the hospitals
are overrun and i don't know to what
degree that was true obviously there was
a lot of mishaps that happened in
hospitals like you know new york all
these elderly people dying but
it was like
a lot of people were like in awe of
china right they're like look how fast
they can act and look oh
i guess yeah maybe like authoritarian
states are kind of good because you can
have this like crazy overnight response
and just like
now we got hospitals now we're taking
care of it now it's on lockdown now
we're going to like solve this quicker
than everybody else right
um because a big frustration to the left
is like why aren't more people taking
backs if everyone take a vaccine and we
just solve this whole thing of course
that's not true but there's this element
of like frustration that they couldn't
like
you know
if you really push it i do think yes
parts of the left wanted to like be able
to physically like restrain you and
inject you with a vaccine not for
nefarious purposes but because they
believed this would cure covet and make
it go away which i think we found out
that it didn't and on the other side
right wingers i think kind of look at
that and be like
hey china can do this sort of stuff to
like fix a problem like why can't we do
this with these other right-wing issues
why can't you kind of wave that wand and
like kick illegal immigrants out as one
example i don't mean to paint everybody
you know on the right is being fixated
on that but
um there were reasons to kind of like we
envy china like the right might say
they're they're strong they're beating
us that was trump's big message like you
know because
they can always afford to look out for
the country's best long-term interest in
the politburo as they plan things and
you know make these really
long-term strategic decisions that
america just can't because we're back
and forth every couple of years in the
congress
but now how the turntables have turned
um
now we're looking at a guy like that and
you go okay but what if right
authoritarianism power empowers you to
make these really quick decisions and
it could be in a helpful direction but
what if it's not what if it's
anti-scientific what if it harms the
individual what if it's not solving the
problem and they're just arbitrarily
enforcing it right that's the dark side
and that's the downside to
governments that have total control over
you
as a population and no individual has
actual rights so i just think the
difference is very stark you know it's a
little over two years later since we
kind of started like the whole you know
shutting business down and things like
that and and uh it just makes me
grateful i guess is what i'm saying it
makes me grateful that i don't live in
an authoritarian hellscape
because uh as cool as it would be to
visit china someday it's a scary place
to think about living isn't it
especially in times of
disaster and the more you can convince
somebody that a disaster or an emergency
is going on
you know or use that as a predicate for
extreme action you got to be careful
with that because you let it happen once
and then oop another emergency you can't
leave your house grandma's dying eh too
bad
now
i'm just gonna you know haters will say
i'm not political dude
well ladies and gents if you're watching
this podcast and i'm speaking you know
that i'm on crait um and not just any
kratom happy hippo herbals kratom
because it's the best it's the best
quality product you can buy on the
interwebs now if you go to
happyhippos.com and use promo code thick
boy you'll get 20
off not once not twice for the rest of
your g-dang life so i encourage you try
create them out i really enjoy it it's
my limitless pill it gets me fired up to
do the pod and act this way
but if you don't like it then maybe
don't take it
you know what it is another day another
podcast another oak and stone clothing
item today i am wearing the green and
black flannel short sleeve shirt love
the way this fits and look it's an xl i
have big arms but it fits at the right
place on my arm so that it doesn't
constrict and it's very breathable i
even wore this when i was in oklahoma it
was super hot but you know what it still
was comfy i own many other flannels i
own levi's flannels i get flannels that
i buy off the internet and i gotta tell
you one of the big things is
how it feels
this shirt feels great it's worth every
penny it's ethically sourced materials
it's an american business that you
should support if you like small
businesses if you like great high
quality menswear and you want to support
me in the podcast
go to
oakenstoneclothing.com and use code
hella
at checkout for 10 off i guarantee you
will not regret
purchasing anything off their site for
yourself or
for your boyfriend he gonna love it
i want to introduce a fun new segment
okay because
you know bro yeah of the year brendan
got me into
watching world star videos he'd always
send us stuff he doesn't really go on
social media so this is kind of like
what he keeps on his fun to entertain
himself and boy oh boy does it entertain
world star now i don't like i'm not
going to spend too long going through it
but it has this great amalgamation of
things it's like you know in one clip
it's like lion eats man alive and then
it's like the baby's new music video you
know so it's just this kind of like all
this viral stuff with a hip-hop
like slant to it but i just saw some
funny headlines that i wanted to
go into and actually going to set up
some other stuff
say what mano says he likes to role play
as a runaway slave during sex with white
women this is my fantasy i play like
they whooping me
now
i just want to dissect that because i
also think
on face value i totally get why it's
being put on worldstar because it's
funny and it sounds funny especially
when you take it out of context we don't
know what the interview was asking if he
was talking about sex and kink and all
that different stuff um so it's sort of
an easy thing to like make a joke out of
and even shame in a lot of ways and it'd
be interesting to see the response that
he gets online and
um
you know
not even the woke crowd but like how
would black people feel about
that i'd be interested in like does that
strike a nerve like would you i could
imagine a lot of people saying you're
wrong for even like saying that out loud
let alone having the thought and it just
reminds me how
there's so much that with attraction and
kink and these different things and
often they're related to childhood
experiences like when you talk to
somebody who's truly a sex addict or has
these you know addiction or other issues
if you listen to dr drew on love line
growing up did you ever do that every
single person who called in
who had some sort of weird thing going
on he goes
you were molested as a kid and they're
like uh yeah how'd you know it's like i
mean just
the most accurate batting percentage
i've ever had but it was like he just
could detect it like that right and
they'd go into it it would be various
forms of abuse or molestation whatever
but there's always something and i'm not
saying by the way that mano
is was abused as a child it just sounds
like i'm going to go into why i think
that's actually an interesting and sort
of innocent kink
um
and
it made me think about a test that
somebody sent me recently that i've been
going to encourage all you to take which
is uh
gonna help you see what kind of sexual
deviant you are sound fun
now
with the mano thing
i think it's an extension and a specific
manifestation of a basic bdsm or sexual
dynamic which is this power exchange of
i'm in control or i'm enslaved right a
lot of these questions on this link that
i'm going to show you guys in a little
bit it was sort of surprised it's like
okay how do you define what kind of
sexual deviant you are right there's
these basic terms that everybody
probably know like dominant submissive
but there's like hunter prey you know
brat
brat uh tamer you don't even like all
these little things it's like whatever
spectrum you can go on you know you'd if
you are somebody who enjoys if you're a
black man who likes
dressing up as a or pretending to be a
captured slave there's
probably somebody else who enjoys
playing the opposite part right and if
you guys can link up and have some
innocent fun
that doesn't sound bad to me
so
but that's just again a specific dynamic
of like
lots of kink involves apparently being
enslaved being trapped being prevented
from moving
uh being punished in some way you know
physical acts of torture that the other
person is consented to
and
and also just a reversal of perhaps your
common dynamics you'll hear a lot of
dominatrixes talk about how the men that
they see that they humiliate and punish
and put in their place and you know make
them their
submissive uh little
slave boy or whatever you'd call it a
lot of these guys are like ceos and
powerful people and you just hear that a
lot that like the thing that this person
is paying for is the opposite of what
they experience in their daily life um
so it's not to say that he like secretly
wants to be a slave it's just like a
nice break from reality so i'm defending
this guy and saying my hot take
on mano wanted to play captured slave is
that sounds healthy to me
and
if you're trying to police other
people's thoughts or kinks i just think
that's a bad direction to go in um
for so many different reasons that i
hope you guys can see but you know the
most you could do is maybe okay i'm
offended that you said it out loud right
if you're maybe a black person who
uh you know whose ancestors were
enslaved and then you hear this
fair enough but to try to say you're
wrong for having those thoughts i don't
know i think that's a slippery slope the
next thing that we're going to look at
and i wonder what's on world star
is not a care in the world
granny snorts a line of cocaine in front
of a crowd like it's nothing
it is nothing dude she's been hitting
bumps for decades
just hit a fat rail dude i'll never
forget this uh
i was in vegas one time about 10 years
ago and
uh was with somebody who was into
partying and yes we did some cocaine
right that was the theme of the the trip
i'm not into it that much where it's
like i'm gonna grab it you know like
some people one of the guys we were with
like you know we'd be like where did he
go you know where'd shawn go and then be
like oh he's in the other hotel room
like dancing by himself in his underwear
just like doing line after line after
line right some people maybe that's your
response to it and maybe you should
think about not doing cocaine ever again
but at some point in the evening
like
the guys that met this girl at the pool
and they're like oh yeah we're gonna
meet up with our friend matt um a little
bit later he's gonna come over to the
room you know he's got some coke or
something
and he walks in and i think the
connection was that like this guy was
australian who's about to meet up with
us and the guys that i was with were
australian and this girl wanted to
connect them
and first of all he walks in and he was
a little person
and that sparked a later debate about
whether or not you should warn
somebody that you're introducing a
little person to that you're a little
person because it would give you like
you know you feel wrong for saying this
but you do want a little bit of warning
just to be like i'm going to shake like
the weirdness often like so i don't have
to be weird around him
yeah but you could also
argue that
if you if you're not taken aback at all
maybe that would offend the little
person like hey did you preface our
meeting with the information that i'm
like you should right
yeah yeah maybe he's yeah he has this
radar of like i'd be more offended you
were acting too normal yeah these these
dudes are talking about me behind my
back hey
everybody if i'm a little person and i
meet somebody new for the first time a
group of people and they have no
reaction whatsoever i'm like let me try
that you can walk out and come back and
you guys are going to acknowledge the
fact that i'm a [ __ ] yeah yeah
and
that's that's a really interesting point
because you your radar would be finely
tuned to like
you know the things people are thinking
you've heard it all but then it's like
now you get to like are people being
excessively friendly to you you know oh
my god hey how's it going i want to be
your best buddy like it's
like many things that are un you know
just out of the ordinary just in the
sense that it's statistically rare to
meet a little person
you know or get pulled over by the cops
or whatever there's this thing going on
there where it's like try to act normal
but it's kind of hard you're thinking
about something else and that's on your
mind and you're trying to avoid it but
maybe they can sense that tension too
but anyway that quickly dissipated
because he had this grocery bag full of
cocaine you know
so it's like
this little guy you know this doll and
he walks in like most people have
baggies or some other i don't know like
maybe a glass container is i could i
haven't seen something but people carry
weed and that's like if you got a [ __ ]
done a cocaine maybe you'd carry it you
know in a little mason jar or something
but he just had like a loose like
ralph's
safeway you know crumpled up
uh bag of cocaine
and i remember like so we were doing
lines and it was like whoa dude this
dude's doing a lot of cocaine for his
size you know like you make a little
rail or whatever and um you know
this tiny little thing and i remember he
was making these like
really long thick lines of cocaine and
he was referring to them as caterpillars
you know in his yeah which is nice
it's not caterpillar mate you know um
just fat rails my caterpillars you know
um
and you know that's that's my story
about a little person here
about cocaine i have other cocaine
stories too of course but
i'd look at this and go there shouldn't
be anything wrong with it because we
drink in public we smoke weed in public
i'm sorry but cocaine isn't that
powerful of a drug i think it's highly
addictive
and i think the stigma the stigmata
comes from
the fact that it's very expensive
it's often abused makes you behave
erratically to a degree but so does
alcohol i just think
alcohol is this kind of
barometer for me of like do you know
unhealthy alcohol abuses you know do you
know how much it damages
not only your
your liver but almost every organ in
your body it degrades you and ages you
and harms you
and undermines your quality of life for
all these different reasons
but we're super concerned about like oh
my god she's putting powder up her nose
in public that's going to last 20
minutes like she's going to be talkative
for 20 minutes
you know have some great business idea
for the next hour and want to talk your
ear off about it you know she's going to
finally get into interior design just
like she'd planned to all these years
but now she's really going to do it he's
going to go back to school
so i just thought that was funny because
why the hell not we should see more
grandma snorting cocaine in the future i
hope
all right we're going to write past this
mark harley meme of the week because we
did it and i just want to play this you
know
with so much going on in the world i
feel like family feud is just one of
these wholesome things that can produce
these spontaneous laughters
right
let's play steve harvey's a little quick
and his question is name something that
follows the word pork
could you back up
what is coupon
a word that follows pork so you'd say
chop right you'd say roll you'd say
um
that's about all i have a pork loin
right he said pork you pine
um and it's just so innocent right it's
so like you're on the
you know you're in the moment you're on
the hot seat and things like that come
up in your brain and i just love the
because it's also like embarrassing for
him in front of his family i think steve
harvey does such a good job at this
stuff like
i unironically like family feud
and i stand by that and it's for moments
like this where it's like what are you
thinking let's just take a second to
dissect your answer right there
a word that comes after pork upon
okay liver king meme of the week
coming in strong when you asked
the liver king how he got so jacked and
it's this little picture from there with
his liver in one hand and a big syringe
in the other so anyway i started
blasting
what is blasting well in
anabolic terminology it's doing a high
amount of steroids relatively relative
to what would be considered a normal
dose or relative to what you would
normally do we're going to actually get
into the idea of blasting and cruising
in a second here and then i want to
click on that link right there
little video anytime i look at liver
king's profiling content so much about
the things that you choose to be
i hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
now
i wanted to start because i don't hate
him right
i don't hate the liver king i do think
it's always going to be an interesting
thing to dissect for various reasons i
think a lot of comedy has come from him
i love the fact that he's become this
phenomenon right
um
but
there's
some interesting things that i've been
hearing about recently that kind of it
makes intuitive sense in a way but like
i don't know if i'd think about the fact
that oh he's not what he claims to be
aside from the you know omnity stuff uh
if i didn't kind of come across this
information but
and nor is it unique to the liver king
but basically what i'm talking about is
the idea that a marketing agency or
individual with a lot of money
gets behind an influencer like this that
they believe they can mold and promote
as a caricature
and
propel them to a really quick
rise in popularity that they can use
to mutually benefit from the sales that
will come from the company that this
influencer is representing um
so we'll call this one
the uh charlotte of the week
i always forget if i do i always go back
and forth on is it fitness fraud of the
week or charlatan of the week i kind of
like the word charlotte and i feel like
i went with that initially but we'll see
whatever i did before is what casey is
going to put up so
this pattern i watched a really good
video on somebody that i wanted to do a
fitness fraud of the week a charlatan of
the week for for a while it's just it's
almost feels like low hanging fruit it's
this guy vincent from v shred and he's
this amazing example of somebody who is
a really handsome
guy with a great genetics and a great
physique uh knows enough in the gym to
be lean and and just look aesthetic but
i don't think he actually truly knows
what he's doing but
one of these guys that starts off in
fitness modeling
has a small following gets somebody's
attention and they say hey
we can make you a star and we're gonna
ready to put money behind you but you
have to kind of sell these products
right um and at some point i blocked him
because
i
was getting so many ads on instagram or
facebook or whatever it was for v-shred
you know the v-shred challenge and how
to get you know lose fat overnight and
how to gain you know muscle and all this
stuff there's always some promise like
you know this one little trick to get
abs and you know get shredded in 30 days
it's always some stupid gimmicky thing
and i just could see that the guy was
not that smart and kind of annoying and
so
i
blocked him and didn't think about him
that much but if you like don't have
youtube premium or you didn't don't
block this guy you might have been
inundated with ads if you have anything
to do with fitness now
i watched a really interesting video
sort of recently when i was thinking
about doing a segment on him and it
basically broke down
exactly what
the company does to target a guy like
this
put all this money behind him and get
this and potentially buy youtube
followers that's one thing that they do
but basically you're trying to create
this marketing funnel
um and over promise to these
you know a certain segment of the
population and this is kind of where
it'll always be
worth dissecting from me because it's
like a vulnerable population novices
they know how to target people who are
just getting into fitness so without the
experience of you know a decade in the
gym and seeing through all this bs and
seeing what really works and really
doesn't from researching and being
around it and really living that life if
you're isolated and you're new to this
game you're susceptible to the idea that
like you need a program you need a trick
you need this product that i'm going to
sell you or even you know a supplement
that promises to like
be more effective than cardio they'll
sell these fat loss pills that are
um you know that they're really billing
is like scientists discovered anytime
you hear that scientists discovered that
this pill is better than three hours of
cardio and it's like what are you
talking about but because supplements
are unregulated by the fda you can get
away with saying almost anything and all
you have
are
people giving bad reviews on the
opposite end but even then
they're going to curate and incentivize
positive reviews it's like hey man like
you know we'll pay the cost of this
thing or give you some incentive or some
product or whatever or catch you in such
a way
when they reach out to you like making
it seem like we're dangling something in
front of you and oh we want to use you
for this promo and we can feature you if
you give a good review so they're also
very good about getting people to say
things that they want
by incentivizing them
but when you really look at the
aggregate of reviews of these programs
it's like even a novice can tell it's
not good it's not affected didn't
deliver as promised yadda yadda but
the point is
when you look at this guy you see
the team and the money behind it and
there's you know if you're spending a
certain amount of money and getting a
certain return on your investment well
then you know in theory you can keep
cranking that number up of investment
and still be reaping in profit you know
if you're getting two dollars back for
every dollar that you're spending on
advertising uh then that works right and
i'll finish up just by saying this guy's
billed as like a guru a fitness expert
somebody you're buying programs from
that he does himself
he doesn't he didn't know what a
deadlift was he he tried to demonstrate
a deadlift this is one of many videos
where he demonstrates
uh exercises incorrectly
he sets up for a conventional deadlift
with
very mediocre form like you could tell
he doesn't have you know
great cues he wasn't ever coached in
this deadlift but he does a conventional
deadlift at the end of the day and he
calls it a romanian deadlift and it's a
small difference but
it's a very novice mistake to make that
you go oh this guy's selling me programs
you know he doesn't know the basics he
uses a kettlebell one time where he like
he catches it and like has the
kettlebell hanging outside here rather
than racking it like if you can you know
like if you do a clean you rack it right
here in your forearm and he has it
hanging out like that so he's like this
and it's like another thing where it's
like objectively you're wrong and you're
leading people to injure themselves so
that's where it becomes this problem
because he just doesn't know anything
yet he's talking to the camera as if
he's an expert
now that brings me to the liver king
apparently and of course he's got a
marketing machine behind him and he was
sort of discovered and promoted um by a
guy who is now his business partner but
saw the opportunity for profit and who
knows what he was like before maybe he
was a some buff dude maybe he really is
in deliver but it calls everything into
question because
when you do this you have to constantly
be on brand and you have to implicitly
deceive your audience by making it seem
like i'm this organic social media
phenomenon
right i just popped up out of nowhere
and overnight i have a million followers
now
of course he does have a viral look and
viral content and just the notion of
like all he does is eat liver and he's
very easy to make fun of and he's
controversial so even getting people to
you know debate in the comments whether
he's nady or not could be a deliberate
strategy to promote the virality but you
just have to remember
follow the money there's a reason why
this guy
seems to be everywhere and keeps coming
up with content and is flying on a
private jet
uh i have no reason to doubt that he
could be successful on his own in
business but
there's a reason you're jet setting and
doing all these different things is
because somebody with a lot more money
is making money off of you and putting a
lot of money behind the marketing of you
as the poster boy for the products that
he's selling that he's also getting rich
on so when people ask me like do you
think that's good it's like could be i
don't know though because i can't trust
the guy
because obviously this is
a product that's being marketed to us
designed specifically to
hack our sense of what we're doing now
for fitness is insufficient and wrong
like all fitness scams no no no tired of
doing a thousand crunches a day try this
two minute ab electro shocker now right
use that basic framework to say no no no
throw all that out
do this totally different thing that's
gonna cost you money
so
i just have this skeptical eye towards
him and i'm going to be investigating
more and giving you some more specifics
as this drama unfolds and
i really want to find out who the guy is
you know and give you more details on
how he was constructed and what liver
king's origin story is
okay
boy oh boy
how much time do we got casey
we've been going uh 37 minutes 37 good
old minutes all right
so
you know
i wanted to do
a help them on steroids real quick where
i have talked about the dc training
protocol and actually decided my next
vlog i'm going to do i'm going to try to
do a dc vlog a pair of vlogs where i
show you the the a and b workouts
for the beginner which is upper body
lower body basically where you do also
biceps and forearms on the leg day to
give yourself a little break because you
just did a bunch of back the day before
you don't want to do it all the same day
anyway
dc training as initially promoted by
dante trudell
dc from dog crap which was his name on
the forums because he couldn't think of
anything better at the time he also had
a
steroid regimen that i wanted to just
express to you as a template for when
you look at bodybuilders you look at
really jack dudes here's how they're
doing it
and it's remarkably simple but i think
still something that people don't want
to confront the reality of right his
basic recommendation in this um
his his
tome as internet his early 2000's
internet tome cycles for pennies he goes
on to
you know talk about
how to get huge bass because if you want
to be an open bodybuilder you just have
to be a monster right and he's basically
like look the hgh and the
insulin and the
the exotic compounds they're just too
expensive for the average bodybuilder
the thing that's gonna get you really
big
is a thousand to two thousand milligrams
of testosterone every week
and maybe you throw in one anabolic that
you rotate through each cycle like
equipoise you know at
600 milligrams a week or you know up to
a thousand i assume but the basic
recommendations are like echo poise or
deca and angelo deconate you know 500 to
1000 a week or
finiplex which is was the
sort of that pharmaceutical version of
trenbolone at 75 milligrams uh
every other day or you know up to 150
milligrams every other day which isn't a
crazy dose like it's a you know another
five it's very powerful so
that's it right and he also says you go
for six to eight weeks hard at a time
drop your test down to a trt level or a
high trt level like between you know 150
to 300 maybe 400 you're just doing tests
and you run clomid and you're on hcg and
just just do enough to get those nuts
started a little bit
again you know just jump start those
nuts once more
and
then that's like three weeks right of
pct while you're running testosterone
and then you're back to writing the
thousand milligrams of test each week so
it's one of these things where you want
to know how to get huge you take a
progressively higher dose of
testosterone and why testosterone
specifically well it is one of the
safest compounds to take for your body
even at higher dosages because your
liver is used to to processing that and
also
um it's super cheap right people are
often shocked you can get a bottle of
testosterone for 20 to 30 bucks
right
if other things are much more expensive
if you're spending hundreds or thousands
of dollars a month on
a pharmaceutical grade growth hormone do
you really know what you're getting out
of it not a lot of people do people some
people swear by it but as far as just
building sheer amounts of
muscle this is like the hardcore
bodybuilding approach that many people
won't talk about but i think it's one of
these things like oh right it's simple
you just crank the doses
and you do it all the time and that
brings me
to another point which is to really
enter into this world this is what i
always tell people
don't just come to me and say i want to
do six weeks of anavar i want to do
sarms for eight weeks i want to take uh
rad 140 i want to think austrian what do
you think
why would you just do one cycle
i honestly think you should just stay
natural i'm not saying like you have to
do cycles and then do a bunch everybody
should no i think you should either stay
natural and come up with a
a strategic way to put on as much muscle
as you want if that's your goal
or
map out like a two-year minimum plan of
going off and on like i said blasting
and cruising the cruising part is of
course when you take the hcg and climate
and lower your doses to refresh your
androgen receptors and also give your
body a break from the six to eight weeks
of really hard training where you're
pushing all these numbers and pushing
for growth then holding onto it letting
the androgen receptors refresh and then
pushing again
that's something that i'm attempting to
replicate or at least we'll be
experimenting with it and i'm on trt now
uh plus five ius of hgh and i'm debating
going on to a high dose of deca and
dball for like six weeks
i have these thoughts to have these
debates in my head i don't know it's
always changing but but i'm at least
thinking ahead and going when if i
started this here what would it do where
could i land how can i fix my diet i'm
always thinking longer term and i think
that's how
you accumulate results because if you're
just going into bank i'm going to dip my
toes in it and do one cycling get out
you're going to be right back where you
started you know if you want to make
significant changes in your physique
over time and just remember
when you get more muscle and get more
ripped it actually becomes harder to get
that more muscle and become a little bit
more than so you're eking out these
smaller gains you know over time after
that first couple years and it doesn't
happen by accident you have to be very
deliberate and i would just encourage
everybody anybody's asking me about that
one cycle whatever
think long term think where would i want
to be in three years and how can i get
there in the safest way possible
and make sure that i'm not just running
trend at 700 a week for three years
because i'm a psychopath and have no
self-control all right okay you had
enough look it up cycles for pennies
do we have time for nice gyms or what
okay let's just run through these come
on let's do it
this guy's doing a muscle up now this is
impressive he's doing a muscle up with a
bench
tied around his waist so it's like i'm a
hater because i can't even do a muscle
up with nothing around my waist but is
this necessary i always just cringe at
this stuff because it's like i hope
there's nobody else at that gym i just
feel like you're in the gym too long if
you feel the need to to make content
like this i don't know that's my side
he's got the chicken wing going that's
uh when one arm likes oh there we go
yeah for the other that wouldn't you
wouldn't count that
i mean it is but it's not good it's like
let's see 10 perfect bar muscle ups
more impressive than a chicken wing with
a rice
right now that i think about it because
you can kind of like i can get my
chicken you can also like do strict bar
muscle ups there's way more impressive
stuff muscle ups oh yeah that's badass
thanks man i really want to learn
because i think it looks cool okay check
out we don't have to use this but um
check out my brother colin he's like
muscle up guy mcgee
um
oh this is
pretty cool
yeah and this is another area which i'd
like to actually get into i think i
already showed you this no
not this one in particular that's really
cool though because whenever i look at a
guy who does
uh calisthenics really well they do
typically have very balanced
aesthetic physiques you know and i just
think it's cool to be able to control
yourself in that way
um
and looks like a really interesting
challenge that i think makes you think
about more than just strength
coordination
and uh mastery of your own body is like
that's freaking cool you know like
there's just no way around it like that
looks badass
and
because everybody's using their own body
weight it kind of creates this like
inherent fairness it's like oh you're
too heavy to do muscle ups lose weight
fatty you know
um you have to compromise something at
the end of the day so i think that's
cool to me that's cooler than just
infinitely getting bigger you know
now what's the other one that we did
part two here we go
oh this is kind of an innocent one but
at the one time my leggings split right
down
my cheeks while squatting during peak
hours
so i want to put because this like this
girl is squatting a lot is that three
plates plus it looks like it might be
385 actually if that's three plates 25
and a 10.
so that's a lot of weight
she's a powerful woman
with a big old badonkadonk so we see why
the pants are splitting but i guess the
question is what would you do would you
immediately go home like would you train
through it [ __ ] yeah if you were her
would it be a different answer versus if
you're a casey garrity
[ __ ] internet handsome yeah i'm podcast
producer i'm probably going home i mean
once you're [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i'm
gonna go wrong thong like because i i'll
freeball it a lot of the time so it's
like i'm not gonna walk around with my
[ __ ] out of my pants you know if i
had boxers it wouldn't be a big thing
but it's like
and i've actually had that happen before
like i
have shown up to work out brendan
chappelle and
i had these like
kino body joggers on that it's like my
thighs are so huge there's always this
friction
between the thighs so like a little hole
create then it's like oh
my left nut is hanging out you know
good thing i'm on steroids and they're
too small to actually pop out of my
sweatpants
otherwise i'd be real trouble but you
see you know you pull out that used gum
right oh look i sat in gum
um you know maybe we'll just end there
maybe we'll do we'll do one more we'll
do one more how about we have nice this
is why we can't have nice gym
oh yeah pov me and my gym bro flexing
with a good ass pump dude on the right
passes out and it looks real too it's
hard to fake a pass out like a not
flinch tell me what you think is a stunt
man it looks like like you see how his
arm doesn't like you almost
most people if you're not a trained
stunt man
it's tough to tell because there's a
jump cut
right and i wonder if that's just the
more interesting part that they kept
flexing but he's like
it looks genuine to me who knows maybe
these kids are gonna come out and say i
mean you could easily just have a mat
right here on the ground and he just
falls onto him right but even if that's
the case you've you sold me on this and
i also know stuff like this can happen
i'll flex sometimes and be like
a goddamn i'm about to pat like you feel
like you're on the verge of passing out
or
you know certain things have this
unexpected effect and especially when
you're fatigued you just worked out
whatever
but
he is sending it he's
right yes he is definitely flexing super
hard holding your breath trying to get
those veins to pop which makes you
lightheaded uh we've all been there one
more baby
okay if ego lifting was a person yes and
this is what i'm talking about when i
bring up partial reps it's like look at
the guys who were doing the partial reps
right does this look like he's got a
system going on he does have a huge gut
going on and he's using about
three inches range of motion with a lot
of bounce and
i don't know you'd love to see how
strong he is on a full range of motion
chest exercise maybe that is doing
something but it's hard to see how you
progressively overload because if you're
using the rest of your body to get the
weight up then you can't ever really
tell
you know if you're doing the same rep or
not because you're just going to be
incentivized to progressively use more
of your
other muscles
and i swear this is so common every time
i go to 24 fitness there's somebody
doing these like little movements or
just doing something wrong and and it
doesn't even look like
a crazy dude like this kind of looks you
know you're wearing a weight belt and
you have a huge gut and you're like
lifting you know five plates for two
inches like mentally something's off
with you clearly
uh i don't think that's a controversial
statement but sometimes you'll see these
guys who are like
you're 35 and like in shape and have
eyeballs
why are you working out like this
why are you making a fool of you must
know that every person in here is going
like jesus christ that's embarrassing
for everybody
but would i ever change that no because
i love the gym
i love the weirdos that come there i
love that it's this big melting pot
i love that it's this melting pot
for all sorts of mental illness
and
and myself included because you know
what i have body dysmorphia
i take off this shirt and i go
am i am i skinny
i'm skinny right like my arms show up on
the screen right
my arms can't go over this oak and stone
flannel but
i'm skinny right
i'm just kidding
you